check your neck that's what they used to
say a lot
check your neck and people would go like
this
or run a cheese check they say it
run a cheese check on your daddy because
you know my dad was real old when i was
born
and when i was young he was even older
and the older i got the older he got and
i was kind of chasing him
you know age chasing and then he died
but
um a lot of times we'd do pizza
you know i was on different sporting
teams or my sister was on a little
sporting team you know
a little lesbian group and then they
would
have a pizza party it used to originally
it was if you won
if you won your team got a pizza party
and then that evolved to even if you got
second
and then it became hell if your team
even if you even had a team
you'd see some kids just we're all
wearing the same jersey never played
anything eating pizza
so it became really just every anybody
could do it
but they used to say run a cheese check
on your daddy because my dad was so
old when he'd have pizza he could you
know the cheese comes off
that pie when you release that slice off
that circle
you really get a lot of that you know
those little little kind of like a
cheese web kind of like a lot of little
cheese little
string cheeses that go from the slice
back to that motherland
that master pie circle and so a lot of
times
you know my dad he didn't know what the
hell was going on
he didn't know you know who was who was
his kid or who was black or who was
white or anything
i mean he didn't know if you were a car
or a person so i remember one time he
put a half a gallon of gas into the back
of my pants
so you just uh you know
daddy would have have him a slice of
that pizza
and he'd have cheese just draped all
over them
and some of the kids would say hey hey
hey hey
run a cheese check on your daddy and
you'd have to just kind of
you know check on his face like that
you'd have to do that dang dang da dang
dang
and cheese check your daddy make sure
you don't have any just cheese just
draping off his face
you know like somebody's trying to speed
lunk off his face or something and
so you know you don't you just want to
make sure you know it was kind of that
deal but um
yeah check check chicken chick
that's a popular term they say chicken
chick
because a chicken you know a lot of
people don't think about a chicken
think about a chicken
now what a chicken
you uh seeing a chicken used to be like
like like coming across a mcdaniels bro
when you're driving
and you you see that you know you see
the the arches he said oh damn that's a
mcdaniel's right there
that's the same in the old days if you
came across a chicken in the 1600
hundreds that's like pulling up on a
restaurant
you know you're riding with your family
you guys are in the uh
you know riding in a horse cart or
whatever you see a chicken they say dad
dad
stop there dad stop at that restaurant
and the restaurant's just over there
it's like
and y'all go over there and slice and
dice
and mom does her thing and that's family
dining that's 1600 family dining man
and the chicken dies but hey
somebody's got to go man and that's
called
that chicken chip good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one